pull up the millennial recording that
was uh
shared with one of our former friends by
the way folks if you have friends like
this you don't need enemies
this is a friend who is sharing this
phone call the main thing
if you haven't seen this already we can
listen to it together and have a
reaction
i just want you to see at the end when
anderson cooper is speaking for 15
minutes
of his reaction to this i want you to
see the reaction of her face
like just see her face at the end that's
what i want you to focus on
but first if you haven't heard it play
it let's hear it together this is july
28th
i'm the same like him i support him i
don't say enough i don't do enough no
where i am
about christmas stuff and decoration but
i need to do it right
yeah but 100 you have no choice
and okay and then i do it and i say that
i'm working on christmas and planning
for the christmas
and they said oh what about the children
that they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom
i i didn't have a chance needs to go
through the process and through the law
but here's my thing hear what you just
said but instead of that
if you just your messaging
you you were so loved through the story
we put it out getting
not emotional it they would not do the
story
because no they are not they would not
do the story because they are
they are they are against what she says
uh you know i certainly doesn't jive
with you know the fox
whole idea i mean from talking to war on
christmas um watch it
it's funny that she would be leading
that that um but you see that certainly
it's one of those traditional roles and
that's just
trying to hold it together i don't know
it's fascinating her talk like that okay
her reaction is because she can't
believe she betrayed her like that and
now she's on tv talking about it she
looks completely embarrassed and ashamed
okay and here's the other thing they
completely misread that melania wasn't
trivializing christmas she was saying
most americans don't really care that
i'm hanging decorations but yet she has
to act like it's a big deal
that's what she was talking about but i
loved anderson cooper's reaction he was
just
failure to compute he was just trying to
find something negative to say about her
in that moment
and that's all he could pull out all i
gotta say is i'm in
favor of legal immigration for anyone
and everyone
who looks like melania trump hundred
percent let him in the country you'd
like popcorn
the best thing that trump has going for
him and i'm not even being facetious
right now the best thing
adam is that melania and trump and
ivanka trump
are certified female studs like they may
listen to anything she said like did she
talk about the
kinkies having a shot at winning what
did she say
actually tell us what she said what was
she talking about she was talking about
collecting hanging out christmas and
stories and getting and getting
and getting uh the the
the border and the moms and the
connected with the kids she's just so
freaking gorgeous that
like she could say whatever the hell she
wants to say like i don't know same with
ivanka trump these
like that's the best thing that trump
has going on he's got good-looking wife
good-looking daughter the [ __ ] show
around him is ridiculous but
he he so let me get this straight taxes
are not going to convert you
no policies are not going to convince
you to convert you but how beautiful
melania is she could conversely vote for
trump
well she said says a lot about your
standards that's where i'm at now that's
where i'm at straight up that is
that's what you want that's the one
thing i'll tell you about trump i'm
being honest here guys
if you're out there in the crowd right
now and you're not like you
you know and everyone knows i'm true
everyone knows this is true you take a
look
you take a look at i'll tell you one
thing you take a look at ivanka trump
and then you take a look at uh not to
get all
weird here you take a look at pete
butterjudge and his uh potential husband
walking down are you kidding me
give me ivanka try give me uh melania
trump any day of the week
okay i'm just saying you look at uh
bernie sanders wife whatever that
[ __ ] is
and then you and then you look at ivanka
trump come on
they got a good-looking situation going
on over here that's all i'm saying
presidency should be judged by i'm just
saying
optics he's done a great job bringing
somebody that's why jimmy carter didn't
get reelected
okay that's a sad scenario people people
could be like this or that or
this or that yeah you know it's true
they're gorgeous
what are you gonna say i don't know what
the hell she was talking about they're
hanging the christmas
i don't know i don't know they like me i
don't care what you're saying just
gorgeous and there it is
there it is i said it there it
that want me to say that is you you say
she is the hottest first lady ever
ever for sure not even close
not even close with jackie o maybe but
not so much i don't know
marilyn monroe was she considered a
first night see calvin
not bad just kidding abraham lincoln's
wife
so would you disagree that she's the
hottest first wife i mean first lady
i wouldn't disagree i mean how could you
she's a freaking supermodel
and i love the way uh how she is
okay i'll tell you what whenever trump
leaves office whether it's in four weeks
or in four years nicholas mattis asked
adam yeah from here until the election
what would trump have to do to win your
vote outside of marrying
hooking me up with the check that looks
like melania done we got sister
you hooked me up melania's sister i take
care of you um
are we going to talk about borah part
two you were gonna make a point because
i
will say this whether trump leaves
office in four weeks or in four years
when she writes a book yeah number one
seller
dad comes out straight up yeah she's got
some secrets she's got some stories
she's smarter than you think she is
she's got worse i spent the course
with her yeah it was impressive you
spent the day with her tell me about
that
with her i interviewed her for a
magazine and we've been tom this whole
time you've been holding up the story
i'm telling stories about weirdos in
costa rica let's hear this story adam's
hero what do you do it was the top floor
of their hotel on in central park okay
you know amazing view how long ago was
this this was probably 2012
maybe this
i was impressed i really was she was
super cool she was professional
she was cordial um she was personable
and i was really impressed i mean
you go in there and you're thinking that
you know maybe you have these
preconceived notions that she doesn't
you know it's just her looks and
everything that got her but man she's an
impressive person
she was very accomplished in russia to
come she's strategic she is a
calculating
individual she is not someone i mean
there's been deals that have been made
i'm sure for her to put up with what
she's had to put up with over the years
i mean
she's a very very brilliant calculating
person and you're right about the book i
think it'd be an amazing read
no question straight up she knows that
trump has cheated on her she has to know
that right
she's not a dummy buddy okay yeah but
she's sticking by her man
there you go i think it's a power is one
hell of a drug man
let's talk because she knows what she
signed up for let's talk about what
let's talk about the real issue here
does this do anything
do you look at this and say unfair
towards her do you look at this and say
you know the media is definitely being
biased and they're not you know
the other day did you see the cnn story
that came out the other day first wives
go to cnn first wives
just type it on google cnn first wives
check this out cnn first lady
is in first uh first uh ladies first
ladies yeah it was on twitter as well
but you're gonna have to go through 50
tweets
uh go to im first ladies we yeah
uh uh go to that just see the first
ladies
recap no no the cnn yeah right there
go below it so they just came out with a
documentary that's the one right there
the cnn special documentary called first
lady so just type in on google first
ladies
first ladies and gentlemen go to images
then go to images
images there you go uh so
stand tapping cnn next to it maybe let's
see if that'll come up
so they just did his series okay on cnn
that one right there click on it
perfect so who's missing on there wow
the current
michelle's big hillary's big she would
have
seen her nancy reagan's the size of
michelle's ear
okay look at that and melania's not on
there
a lot of people are not when did this
come out this just came out a couple
days ago that's
unacceptable i mean look at hillary
don't accept this just came out four
days ago yeah i mean even for marketing
purposes you've got to put more
100 yeah but but i tell you for me
again this is not scripted right what
melania did
for me a couple things happened number
one that woman
who's gonna hire her i actually want you
to ask the question so you're about to
interview her and hire her would you
consider hiring her hell no
would you no she's basically leaking
stories she's leaking secrets
she's no no she is leaking a private
phone call with her friend
would you hire somebody like that no
obviously not okay so she probably got
paid for doing this
sharing this [ __ ] she lost her
credibility how much you got paid
probably 20 grand
it's not even that much the point i'm
trying to make to you is imagine that's
your mom
say that's your mom forget about it it's
your mom it's your wife it's your sister
actually look at it from that standpoint
that is your mom your mom just
leaked somebody's conversation what do
you tell your mom what are you doing
so so imagine you're going to work every
day and that's your mom
so you your mom is that's your mom your
mom is that person
oh my gosh i would never and then i'm
not trusting you because you come from
that lineage that's the kellyanne conway
one of the worst things you could do is
to cut
the person that hired you to be their
alliance to trust you to open up and cry
like this freaking rule number one of
character
if some it might dude my enemies i know
stuff on my enemies that are very very
dark thing i still won't leak it to
people
okay i still won't look at the people
that's what are you doing with that
you know unbelievable what are you doing
with something like that that's number
one second thing
i felt her pain i sympathize with her
i'm stuck you know what
i can see what she's going through i can
see the fact that she's ousted no one's
probably reaching out no one's probably
talking to her no one's probably doing
anything with her
you know who's contacting her definitely
not george bush's wife because
she doesn't like trump so she's not
calling and saying is there anything we
can help you out with no they're because
they're part of obama's and clinton's
camp they're on the complete opposite
side
these guys are now so she's alone she's
by herself who is she talking to
that knows her experience i don't think
anybody does but uh
so you know again when i saw this i was
kind of disappointed to see
that a advisor that's a friend of yours
that's going to come out talking like
that for you but i actually think it
helped that melania because the world
saw a different side of melania
yeah i think we're like you know what
damn what was the last comment that she
could do it on fox but she didn't want
to why because she knows that's easy
that's a layup no she wants she knows
she doesn't want to do it on fox because
everyone's going to say of course fox
would do a story like this
she wants that story to be on the cnn or
abc's or cbs or nbc or something like
that
can you imagine no one wants to do a
story on the first lady
how many people would watch it it's a
money-making opportunity still say no to
it you know i was listening to the
conversation i was wondering when did it
click for that woman that
she was going to release this tape like
i felt listening to it
she was setting her up i thought during
that conversation
she was egging her on encouraging her
and already thinking about selling that
[Music]
thing